as we are a multicultural radio station
we always want to give her ears to both
sides of the story what the young people
think of Germany's refugee policies
that's the topic of this week's edition
of the culture clash radio show
co-hosted by Louise evolve Louisa
produces the show for multi cult FM a
radio station with an international
focus for about seven years now the
program's been available over the
Internet the same manner a beta buzanis
what I especially like about my work is
that were a young international team
we're driven and are not afraid to deal
with topics outside the mainstream and
that's what I really appreciate here at
me as Edward the radio station is
located in Berlin's multicultural
Kreisberg district before Louisa takes
us to her first tip we stroll through
the local indoor market which houses the
radio studio this is a nice place to
shop relax and eat
yet no Monica mocked you often have
lunch in the market but i really like
here is the smell of freshly baked
croissants I like to get them from the
French bakery what do you mean you've
seen your band pencils
the indoor market is right on bagman
straße Louise's first tip for kreuzberg
the street retains some of its Belle
Epoque charm it's a favorite among
Berliners and tourists alike bearman
straße has a multicultural Flair with an
intensity of international cafes
restaurants and shops not commonly found
in Berlin Louisa especially likes a
secondhand shop named colors in a local
courtyard
these are laden here triggered an
eternity of this shop reflects quotes
Berg's alternative charm really well I
think if you're on the lookout for
interesting and off-the-wall clothes
this is definitely the right place and
the strange thing is you don't pay per
item but by the kilo for kilo a short
walk away is the hill that gave
kreuzberg its name and one time
vineyards covered its slopes now it's
known as Victoria Park
on the summit is a monument
commemorating the Wars of liberation
against france during Napoleonic rule
yeah I think lights back on if you guys
only hit my gun scanner I like to come
up here to get away from Berlin's hustle
and bustle hmm let's hear what I'm
really like here is the view it's so
beautiful and fine especially with the
hills on one side and the wide open
spaces on the other side by traffic
avisan
in the evening louisa gives us her third
tip she walks past was toughest game
music about the city's most famous kabob
stand along the Mearing damn boulevard
people queue here day and night Louise
is headed for Madame Claude a barn ish
Liz ashes tour an area known for its
counterculture nightlife
madam Claude to is multicultural Louisa
meets friends from Ireland people at
surrounding tables are speaking Russian
German and who knows what the
proprietors of French the bar is located
in a form of brothel the interior design
turns conventions upside down
yeah yes it is everything's pups are
down and I like it sometimes I need
friends here for a beer but above all I
like the music I've discovered some of
my favorite bands here they don't have a
cover charge it's all financed by
donations
madam Claude is multicultural
alternative creative quintessentially
coins fair
you